des orgies pantagruélique des beuveries
gargantuesque cessa rabelais enfin c'est
ce qu'on veut bien nous faire croire
ce matin là dans les caves de la maison
natale de l'écrivain la confrérie des
entonnoirs rabelaisien est à l'oeuvre
[Musique]
sur la liste des intronisés des
spécialistes de rabelais venus du monde
entier pour rendre hommage au célèbre
tourangeau mais au fait que reste-t-il
de rabelais rabelais c'est chinon et
chinon c'est rabelais enfin c'est ce que
pense pierre coulis
pierre et viticulteurs de génération en
génération et c'est lui qui a eu l'idée
de créer la confrérie des antes honneur
rabelaisien vous savez les joyeux
drilles en costume rouge et or les
mythes les confréries souhait 762 en 61
exactement la formation du bureau
bon on en a fait un costume a été créé
en fait un bureau de forme et on est
allé voir des gens plus anciens nos
parents et on april évolution qui nous
est surprise a été considéré très vite
au bout de quelques années comme ça a
dit que soit la presse par guillot comme
la seconde conférence parce que tu es
pro chinon à un coude exploit
extraordinaire que nous nous sommes co
chinon allons pas de fausse modestie
pierre vous avez quand même intronisé
une belle brochette de célébrités
sans oublier qu'ils étaient vraiment
rabelais les gens sont toujours à
blesser larripa ra blessés les
personnages bon en réalité à rabelais se
ficher des rois de france et des
personnages de red france pour savoir
que s'il n'y avait pas eu les libellés
rabelais aurait été pendus
[Musique]
rabelais est né à la fin du xvème siècle
à la devignère une des propriétés de son
père avocat à quelques kilomètres de
chinon il en partira à l'âge de 8 ans
avec des souvenirs plein la tête
un devinière pour rabelais représente
effectivement la maison d'enfance et la
maison des souvenirs c'est la maison
auquel ils accrochent une grande
importance puisqu'elle prend une place
centrale dans la guerre picrocholine
notamment c'est le coeur de l'ouragan
c'est à dire que tout tourne autour
d'elle et elle n'est jamais atteinte
c'est assez formidable et en même temps
il y place la naissance de gargantua et
le rôle de grande musique et seniors de
la devinière donc c'est une maison avant
tout une maison d'enfance une maison
d'inspiration pour le roman qui est sans
doute le plus célèbre de rabelais garde
à la fois moines et anticlérical
catholique et libre penseur médecins et
bon vivant
l'homme était plein de paradoxes c'est
ce qui a séduit la spécialiste japonaise
aya iwashita quand je lis rappeler
précisément avec mes professeurs c'est
il y à un autre monde où il yad'autres
monde qu'on peut découvrir donc
et c'est bien évidemment c'est ça
concerne l'arrière plan politique et
religieux aussi mais si on connaît cet
allié cet arrière-plan
l'histoire est plus beaucoup plus
intéressantes et amusantes au sic
derrière la bouffonnerie se cacherait
donc une critique des élites rabelais va
se moquer des tenants des pouvoirs
s'étaient tous les représentants du
pouvoir que ce soit le pouvoir religieux
1 qu'il conteste manière virulente les
théologiens de la sorbonne sont ses
premiers jeux adversaires les
sorbonnards gaulle et sorbo nicole comme
il les appelle
s'étonnant d'un savoir confiné savoir
qui réduit au contraire lui veut cette
renaissance du savoir cette
réinterprétation des textes
[Musique]
magnifique aura blaisy encore
aujourd'hui naissent des vocations
philippe blot et est aiguilleur du ciel
il fait désormais revivre la tradition
des poires tapées que l'on retrouve dans
les guerres picrocholines ses célèbres
guerre de voisinage décrite dans
gargantua nous quand on a commencé il ya
une quinzaine d'années on s'était posé
la question comment rabelais pouvait les
manger c'est vrai qu'ils veulent le 26
noms melgven chilon de l'époque c'est
par le vin qu'on a aujourd'hui
donc on a on a été plus se chercher sur
ce qu'ils pouvaient boire et on a trouvé
le vin d'hypocras en fait c'était le vin
d'hypocras qui était une recette qui
était qui servait surtout à faire à
rendre les 20 qui avait qui avait
commencé à se piquer buvable avec cette
recette ancestrale le village de
rivarennes près de chinon se retrouvent
aussi dépositaire de l'esprit
rabelaisien leur adresser toute une
philosophie de l'art de vivre c'est à
dire qu'on va on va choisir on va
choisir les produits on va on vient de
choisir les vins on va faire cesser tout
un ensemble la larrabee
[Musique]
lorsque l'on est arabe les i on
n'échappe pas à son destin sur les
collines du chinonais bertrand coulis le
fils de pierre a grandi à l'ombre de
l'écrivain
[Musique]
en egypte une culture toujours la
culture c'est ressent on ne la prend pas
c'est presque devinez quoi
c'est ce qu'on perçoit tous les jours
toutes les fêtes rabelaisienne convenu à
chinon ça vous donne un esprit la façon
de recevoir la façon d'accueillir de
parler de son métier
rabelais présent et même face à un
client américain
bertrand n'oublie jamais de relier la
culture des vignes à la culture
littéraire chasse sur place
les vignes sont à l'endroit où se situe
la généalogie des géants de rabelais le
nom de l'olive
c'est le lieu que l'on retrouve dans les
livres où il y as garé quand tu as
pantagruel les plus célèbres géant de
l'oeuvre de rabelais rabelais box
françois rabelais nous accompagne tout
le temps cette notion d'humanisme de
philosophie et c'est là aussi où dans
notre métier de vigneron se retrouve on
retrouve notre nos valeurs de de partage
de communication d'humanité de tolérance
et ça c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans
l'oeuvre de françois rabelais
[Musique]
à tours la ville à rabelais abrite
l'institut européen d'histoire et des
cultures de l'alimentation
ici on étudie très sérieusement la
gastronomie à travers les époques et
pour bruno lorioux rabelais
l'ecclésiastique défier sa hiérarchie en
célébrant la gourmandise ce vilain péché
réprimés par l'église cette oeuvre fond
elle est un petit peu dans le
prolongement je dirais de ce qui
existait auparavant c'est à dire une
tradition littéraire qui consistait à
célébrer effectivement les bons les bons
mais à travers les mots donc une espèce
d'ivresse du texte de folie du texte
c'était une manière d'exprimer la
gastronomie d'une certaine manière parce
que pour l'église ça n'était pas un
discours qui méritaient versa n'était
pas un sujet qui mérite est
véritablement un discours autonome un
discours en tant que telle n'est pas de
discours gastronomique tôt possible donc
ça voulait dire qu'il fallait passer par
des sortes de voies clandestines
subreptice pour exprimer ce plaisir de
manger
souvenez-vous les ripailles des géants
de rabat sont aussi une façon d'exprimer
des valeurs humanistes
[Musique]
un détail qui n'a pas échappé à jacky
d'alès cuisinier en touraine de père en
fils agréable et c'est là partagent le
temps le partage l'amour de deux visites
la bonne cuisine
mais bon la bonne cuisine ça veut pas
dire non plus des choses sophistiqués
des vrais produits des bons produits
puis et puis voilà c'est tout puis le
temps mais moins graves les i7 va
moi je me cale manifester poursuivre à
saint pierre une poulette arrive cette
truculence tout rabelaisienne y noms de
la cuisine où officie aussi le fils
fabrice et quand jacky à la nostalgie de
cette époque où l'on festoyaient sur de
grandes tables
il peut contempler dans sa salle de
restaurant cette évocation très
contemporaine de la scène le tableau de
léonard de vinci
nous à cette scène avec ses verres de
vin rouge cc rabelaisien partage là
c'est le vrai partage partage 2-2
toutefois la musique de y'a pas que toi
il ya eu l'époque à nourriture y arrives
tu sens qu'il ya quelque chose et plus
en plus une amie marie madeleine dans un
coin je trouve ça génial
magnifique
les banquiers pantagruélique n'ont pas
disparu ils ont lieu plusieurs fois dans
l'année à chinon
[Musique]
au coeur de la ville médiévale à
l'endroit même où la famille de rabelais
comme d'autres familles de la ville
possédait une cave pour entreposer son
vin les caf pacte sous le château ont
été conservés comme elle était à
l'époque
j'ai jamais vu le fond
avant qu'elle soit fermée le
garde champêtre tous les soirs battez le
tambour à l'entrée pour qui les enfants
perdus retrouve la sortie donc cédé
cammas est immense avec des rues très
sombre il n'y a pas de lumière donc
c'est le monde souterrain c'est une
ville souterraine
les caf pacte appartiennent au syndicat
des vins de chinon et ce soir c'est bien
l'esprit de rabelais qui flotte sous les
voûtes rassemblant viticulteurs et
universitaire c'est une expérience
inoubliable est formidable
[Musique]
chacun a intériorisé une certaine idée
de rabelais
comment se trouve confronté
à la devignère l'abbé solide c'est quand
même assez d'être ordinaire parce que
doligé de faire constamment le saut
entre ce qu'on imaginait rabelais sont à
lui de rappeler ce que nous a apporté
et puis
pierre coulisses se souvient d'un voyage
de la confrérie en syrie comme du début
d'une prise de conscience réelle à
compter d'un lieu aussi rien
qui m'a dit mais vous ne voulez pas
qu'on vous représentez rabelais d'être
porteur du message et un blessé
extraordinaire
c'est le message au monde que
recherchent toutes les nations c'est la
mode me
mais c'est aussi le monde de la culture
c'est l'abbaye de thélème c'est le
respect de l'homme faisaient en vain
y'a tout derrière la démesure et la
paillardise l'auteur du torche cul et
des guerres picrocholines était un
personnage bien plus profond et
progressiste qu'il n'y paraît une source
d'inspiration inépuisable pour le
chinonais sa terre natale
[Musique]